[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir
je ne sais pas si c'est parce que nous
sommes samedi après midi que le bon soin
est timide mais nous sommes tous des
êtres humains on a besoin de la chaleur
des uns des autres
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir voila
merci beaucoup
or ceux ci
on l'appelle à bada
chez les yoruba
que vous retrouvez tout au long de la
côte en afrique de l'ouest
et ça
appel gobbi
alors vous ne verrez ni le gobie ni la
baraque comme ça
sur d'autres continents apa le continent
africain
et cela veut dire quoi cela veut dire
que l'afrique est riche de sa culture
de ses enfants
et de ses idées
en avril dernier j'étais habillé comme
ceux ci au nigeria car un singe devant
interpellé dix jeunes hommes
on est tu la signification du message
que tu véhicules selon le côté vers
lequel tu passes ton kobe tu dis non il
m'a dit lorsque le gobi est penché du
côté de droit cela veut dire que tu es
un homme marié mais qui encore de
l'espace à la maison pour accueillir une
nouvelle femme
lorsque le gaby est penché du côté
gauche
cela veut dire que tu es un homme marié
qui n'a plus d'espacé à la maison pour
accueillir une femme je pense que le
mieux est bien orienté et finalement
lorsque le gobi est orienté devant cela
veut dire que tu es un homme qui aime
s'amuser et toute femme qui vient vers
toi ne doit s'attendre à aucun
engagement parce que toi tu t'amuses et
tu continues ton chemin vous voyez
combien l'afrique est riche
le culture d'idées et s'étend pas aux
idées que je suis ici cet après midi
partager avec vous
compan je pense que nous pouvons
construire
l'afrique le pays dont nous rêvons aussi
il ya onze ans
j'ai écouté le discours d'un célèbre
afrique et américains qui est sénateur
[Musique]
du nom de barack obama et kiala aux
élections présidentielles dans son pays
et le disait dans son discours je me
souviens bien que l'une des raisons
fondamentales pour lesquelles il était
en train de candidater aux élections
présidentielles de son pays
bien qu'étant un africain américain
était le fait qu'il pensait très souvent
à quel type de pays
il voudrait laisser derrière pour ses
deux filles sasha et malia
aujourd'hui quand je pense à ces propos
dont je ne mesurait pas la portée en ce
temps
je me rends compte
que le candidat devenu président a
effectivement transformé son pays après
deux mandats de quatre ans
obama à rêver d'un pays pour ses filles
elle s'est levée il a agi et l'a
construit le pays dont il rêvait
et vous et moi et nous que faisons nous
très souvent lorsque nous considérons le
continent africain
nous sommes souvent me très découragés
par les réalités quotidiennes qui sont
très dures manque d'accès à l'énergie
électrique manque d'accès à l'eau
potable en danse et en soins de santé de
qualité manque d'accès à l'éducation de
qualité manquent ou insuffisance des
infrastructures et je ne cite plus la
liste est longue
en regardant ces réalités il est très
facile de se dire
ce n'est pas pour demain le
développement je me concentre sur ma vie
je me bats pour moi et ma famille et le
reste on verra
mais j'aimerais que nous réfléchissions
à une chose si chacun de nous ici se bat
pour sa vie si vous battez vous battez
chaque jour pour votre vie et vous
réussissez finalement et que vous
laissez à vos enfants une bonne
éducation
vous laissez des biens matériels et
financiers en héritage mettez vous ne la
laissez pas un pays fort derrière
il suffit d'une crise d'une crise et
tout est parti il suffit d'une crise
financière et l'argent laissé en banque
est perdu il suffit d'une crise
immobilière et la maison que vous aviez
bâti ou acheter après tant d'années de
travail ou que vous avez laissé à vos
enfants
il suffit d'une crise immobilière pour
que cette maison ne disparaisse il
suffit d'une crise économique l emploi
où l'entreprise
deux mois
et disparaissent et finalement il suffit
d'une crise politique et la liberté
d'aller et de venir
sera également perdu et même vous ou vos
enfants pour répéter vous pourriez
courir le risque
vous pourriez courir le risque d'être
des prisonniers
ou des réfugiés dans vos pays
tout ceci parce que vous êtes battus
pour vous même et vous avez laissé la
sphère du développement dans la main des
gouvernants disant ce n'est pas mon
affaire dans un bateau
tous les individus peuvent être épanoui
et si le bateau coule tout le monde
roule
vous avez beau réussi individuellement
si le pays coule
vous allez poulet
ne serait ce pas une aberration
de courir toute sa vie
juste pour voir que tout ce que vous
avez bâti disparaissent ou que vos
enfants désormais souffrent les mêmes
souffrances que vous aviez souffert
alors sachez une chose si vous ne faites
rien pour pays
rien ne se passera si vous faites
quelque chose pour votre pays votre pays
avant serein
je voudrais vous inviter à prendre
l'engagement
nous construire le pays de vos rêves
pour ce faire si vous avez pris cette
décision permettez moi de partager trois
pistes avec vous principe numéro un
ayez l'aude a cité de croire
aucun rêve ne peut être accomplie c'est
le porteur du rêve ne croient pas en
leurs rêves
enfin que notre cerveau ne se met en eux
où trouver les solutions
problème que nous rencontrons pour
pouvoir trouver le chemin vers le rêve
il faudrait que non il y a une foi
inébranlable
il est une conviction une abnégation que
oui c'est possible
très souvent j'entends les gens dire le
développement non
c'est pas pour maintenant ce n'est même
pas pour demain j'entendais dit c'est
pas la peine
j'entends nos mères et nos paires disent
oh
c'est peut-être votre génération mais
non c'est fini
alors un pays n'est rien sans ses
citoyens si les citoyens ne décide pas
de faire quelque chose le pays ne
changera pas je voudrais vous inviter à
croire le rêve
beaucoup choisissent d'être cynique et
d'autres vont même très loin en
maudissant le pays en ce pays qui ne
vaut rien ce pays qui est foutu en ce
pays vaut mieux sortir tu ne peux pas
réussi dans ce pays
beaucoup disent ah
au point que la vie et la mort sont au
pouvoir de la langue et que ceux qui
lèvent se rassasie de ses fruits
et que celui qui porte un rêve et qui
est tout le temps après de modi'in
solaire ne pourrait jamais espéré
accompli son rêve est donc que les
africains qui rêvent de meilleurs
lendemains pour leur pays ou leur
continent mais qui sont tout le temps de
me dire leur pays au nom
ne pourront pas réaliser ce rêve
prenons un exemple en avril 2019 le
programme régional pour la protection
intégrée du cotonnier en afrique ou aux
thoniers africain prp icea a tenu sa
12ème réunion ici à cotonou au bénin
et c'est en souhaitant que l'on
apprenait que le bénin est passé
troisième dans le classement des
meilleurs producteurs de coton en
afrique
troisième derrière la côte d'ivoire et
le mali
est troisième devant le burkina qui
pendant des années a été le premier pays
producteur de coton en afrique
lorsque cette nouvelle a été rendue
publique
beaucoup ont dit oh non c'est pas vrai
ce n'est pas normal le bénin ne paie pas
beaucoup doutaient parce que pour eux le
bénin ne peut pas réaliser sa
performance lorsqu'elle avril 2015
le bénin a connu un recul de 38% dans sa
production cotonnière
j'ai entendu des gens dire c'est normal
c'est le bénin qu'est ce qu'on peut
espérer d'un tel pays trop 8% de recul
et tu a étonné
dont les fils et filles du continent
sont en accord lorsque ça va mal et
qu'on me dit est à savagnier et refuse
de croire
nous irons ou si nous refusons de croire
le rêve
je voudrais lancer un défi à chacun ce
soir de prendre la décision de croire en
leurs rêves que le pays peut se
développer si vous prenez cette décision
alors je vous donne le principe numéro
deux la nécessité de s'impliquer et
d'agir
beaucoup de personnes disent et critique
les uns pays le niveau de développement
de leur pays
ça ne va pas le pays n'est pas
développée mais ne font rien ou le
développement du pays
mon coco pour leur vie
mais ne lève pas le doigt ou le pays
chacun devrait se poser la question en
allant au lit chaque jour ou chaque
semaine ou chaque mois ou chaque année
qu'est ce que j'ai fait pour le
développement de mon pays
alors je vous propose trois niveaux
d'engagement c'est quand le pays est
comme une pyramide
à la base les populations au milieu les
leaders des preneurs de décision et ont
resserré les détenteurs de pouvoirs
exécutif législatif et judiciaire
ce que vous pouvez faire si vous pouvez
cette question en tant que citoyen vous
pouvez déjà commencer à la base
parvenez des actions directes vis-à-vis
de vos compatriotes dans les quartiers
les villages dans les villes dans les
départements des actions telles que des
campagnes de sensibilisation sur des
sujets précis des ateliers de formation
et de renforcement de capacités dans le
domaine donné vous pouvez choisir
campagne de salubrité vous pouvez
également choisir
d'être des citoyens qui refusent de
partager les mauvaises informations ou
les rumeurs au risque d'hypothéquer
l'avenir de votre pays
car des guerres et des troubles à
l'ordre public peuvent l'être simplement
à travers des messages qui sont trop
mais qui ont été partagés
vous pouvez également choisi d'être des
citoyens qui s'impliquent et qui avait
les autres à s'impliquer
une manière de s'impliquer c'est d'être
un citoyen qui paie ses taxes et ses
impôts c'est d'être un citoyen qui
connaît les lois de la république
qui levait en eux qu'ils les respectent
c'est d'être un citoyen qui amène les
autres également à connaître les lois de
la république et finalement d'être un
citoyen
il ya un respect profond
pour le bien public le bien qui nous
appartient à tous
n'oubliez pas si vous ne faites rien
pour votre pays
rien ne se passera si vous faites
quelque chose pour votre pays le pays
avant sur en mai lorsque vous avez agi
au premier niveau d'engagement
vous pouvez aller au niveau 2 essayer
d'influencer les dirigeants dans les
différents secteurs d'activité et dans
les régions géographiques du pays
les leaders ceux qui prennent les
décisions
en quoi faisant en menant des campagnes
de plaidoirie
en essayant de faire la participation
citoyenne dans l'élaboration des
politiques publiques ou dans les prises
de décision
et en faisant la veille citoyenne pour
vous assurer que les décisions qui ont
été prises sont appliquées
c'est votre deuxième niveau d'engagement
si vous ne comprenez pas quelque chose
au lieu de s'asseoir et de critiquer
saisissez vos autorités dans le quartier
dans la ville
ecrivez-le et faites le suivi dit je ne
comprends pas ça a expliqué mattel
c'est au moins une action que de rester
et de critiquer et de ne rien voir
changer
faites-le est observée je ne parle pas
de théorie je parle de faire
expérimenter et tout au moins là où je
vis dans mon quartier
tellement de jeunes l'ont fait et ont
partagé les témoignages avec moi soyez
des citoyens qui s'impliquent
lorsque vous avez le rêve qui pouponne
en vous portez le rêve à travers des
actions
herminie avec le troisième niveau
si vous avez fait l'engagement à la base
l'engagement au milieu de la pyramide et
que votre rêve n'est toujours pas
accompli lancez-vous
chercher à devenir des gouvernants
également au sommet des détenteurs du
pouvoir exécutif ou législative ou
judiciaire entré en politique fait le
militantisme
au moins vous n'allez pas mourir sans
avoir déjà combattu le bon combat
en conclusion le troisième principe
c'est de construire sur des valeurs rien
ne se fait dans la fosse était il faut
de l'intégrité
il faut de l'excellence il faut de la
discipline et de la persévérance
soyez intègre dans tout ce que vous
faites soyez excellent dans tout ce que
vous faites
soyez discipliné jusqu'au bout et soyez
persévérant
l'afrique dans l'est
trente prochaines années et on aura le
monde et sa grâce à nous sa population
ya 30 ans l'asie était comme l'afrique
mais des pays comme la corée du sud qui
était pauvre et qu'ils maintenaient la
onzième puissance économique
singapour qui était pro et qui est la
deuxième économie la plus compétitive au
monde ont étonné le bénin peut étonner
le togo peut étonner
le nigeria le liberia la guinée la
centrafrique le congo mais grâce à leurs
citoyens qui porte le rêve qui agissent
et qui construisent sur des valeurs les
50 prochaines années nous appartient si
nous ne faisons rien rien ne se passera
si nous faisons quelque chose
nos pays avant seront je vous remercie
[Musique]
pas